hey good to see you again well today i
have some good news for you
today we're going to talk about the key
food that can actually increase an
additional five years to your lifespan
there was a study done on over 2
240 people
over 65 years old for 11 years
this is what they found regular
consumption
of oily fish in your diet can increase
your lifespan by almost five additional
years that's significant they found that
omega-3 fatty acids in your red blood
cells
are a very good mortality risk predictor
now on the flip side
being a regular smoker can decrease your
lifespan
by 4.7 years
so if you do smoke on a regular basis if
you quit smoking and you start consuming
oily fish that can add almost 10 years
to your lifespan that is huge okay so
what does omega-3 do to your body well
it contributes to forming cell membranes
it reduces inflammation it decreases
triglycerides it counters the omega-6
fatty acids that are in most of your
foods it decreases your risk of certain
types of cancer it can help you reduce
fat on your liver it can decrease
depression and anxiety it can decrease
pain it can decrease the risk of getting
adhd it can help with asthma it can
decrease the risk of getting alzheimer's
as well as increase your heart function
all right so those are all really great
benefits
but i'm going to give you a list of the
best sources of omega-3 fatty acids
number one cod liver oil
and cod liver
okay this is what i consume on a regular
basis i'll do half of this can once a
day
and it's it's pretty tasty all right
next best source would be salmon
make sure it's well caught then we have
sardines
fish eggs
mackerel
herring now if you're a vegan or a
vegetarian you could do english walnuts
chia seed i realize when you're doing
that you're getting the precursors for
omega-3 fatty acids so
you're not going to get the full amount
in which case i would highly recommend
getting your omega-3 from
algae all right you know what to do
start consuming omega-3 fatty acids
hey before you go if you're benefiting
from any of my content
i would love to hear about your success
story
please share it in the link down below